okay let me just step out of that
i remember not having seen the smith
mora
in many years and then having to
suddenly play
mark assaman who
convinced me that
in fact it's just a serious opening and
he's alright it is
so
[Music]
i'll just shuffle around for a while and
see if i can improve my pieces
but i think if
the bishop had gone to f4 then there are
more immediate problems for black
at least harder decisions that he has to
take
i assumed that
[Music]
this was not a bad thing for me
okay that's a pity for white because
he's just walked into
this pin unless i have missed
no queen h5 g6 so
that is good enough
so now i take and then i think i'm going
to swap this
[Music]
yes i am
for a second i was worried about b4 but
that's not really happening
i mean b4 i just come in c7 and
queen f4 or something e7 okay
finally i'm happy i'm a happy man i can
play bishop d7 and now i have bishop
season's coming
and that really ought to be it
okay um i mean let's
force him to swap something
let me take that i think
i can get some more pieces out of the
board
and yeah this one's over as well because
well like it's just simply an exchange
up
but i think white had some interesting
tries here and there
of course running quite fast
i mean i'll almost certainly pick up the
pawn on d2 and then
[Music]
the time it takes my king to walk over
[Music]